okay let's go to cool Depp Oh - that's
how I have this person who's from China
cool Depp Oh - I don't know what that
means is that is that your name
hey no hey how you doing this cool drop
who's dropping - yes sir I think that's
still my name on us yeah yeah cool drop
Oh - on YouTube okay yeah it's me again
yeah I'm Way more sober and for everyone
um actually watching no I wasn't doing
the wacky tabacky I'm not trying to get
my mother I'm not trying to get my head
chopped off so strong although I want to
shout out everybody live in China right
yes sir yes I do I live and work in
China um also thank you I appreciate
that I want to shout out seven five
seven James I'm active risen from seven
five seven at Newport News Virginia well
at least at a Newport News City Virginia
and or the surrounding area they can
also be York County but that was pretty
cool to hear one from my area that's
pretty dope but I do have an assessment
question or you know topic the trade war
in the sense that it happened on the
farmers that are you know in abroad and
in our country and I feel like India is
really undercutting the sex the
devastating effect is having
domestically in abroad for wonder for
instance a three of my friends that
really into the markets we are we uses a
this app in China called WeChat and
they're really talking about how China
suffering from a food shortage of sorts
and right now they're actually calling a
bunch of hogs here in China and a lot of
them say I think that because of this
trade war is going to affect their
importance of what they love the meats
are desired most in that sport and um I
actually told them yo did you know that
in our in my state in Virginia in VA
they own Smithfield packing meat packing
a Chinese company own Smithfield meat
packing which is one of the largest
Meatpacking companies in the world right
especially when it comes to pork
products and there's no tariffs on port
okay so yeah I'll ticular question
therefore the objective but the question
itself is how do you feel how do you
what do you know about or how do you
think the tears are really actually
going to set China when it comes to food
grant I'm Matt granite considering the
fact that they own a large percentage of
our farming our farmland and our
meatpacking company
I couldn't address that industry
specifically but from the from the sort
of long-form more academic analyses of
the tariffs that I've read China is much
better positioned to weather the effect
of the tariffs then is the United States
both in terms of the countries that
China the options that China has in
terms of gifts to their economy relative
to the options that the United States
has so my overall opinion I can't speak
about the meat industry specifically is
that China is going to be able to much
ease much more easily whether the
effects of the tariffs than the United
States that's what that was my sauce
exactly because one they have they have
so many options and one of the options
that they have is the United States in
itself and it's not being wholeheartedly
addressed like yo wait um china owns in
bed china owns Smithfield I say china
owns because you know if a company in
China owned something china owns it sure
and and these are things that a lot of
my friends especially like the the more
educated ones they then I feel like then
they're really overlooking I think it
has a drop I think you're making a very
good point and it's interesting actually
being there firsthand and seeing it and
by what Vermont do you teach English and
China remind us what you do own I think
ceramics and I teach social studies and
this is uh these like these are topics
that I you know dive into I'm sort of
like you but I watch a lot more videos
and you do and are you are you live
there permanently or are you there for a
specific amount of time
I am I go back and forth I normally
visit during the summer and I come back
during the school year and travel during
their holidays there nationally
and you like you like living there I do
I actually do I'm safe I haven't been
pulled over by any cops I can actually
walk near a cop whistling backwards and
skipping they won't excuse me sorry
oh I did it again don't worry mom and
they don't say anything appreciated Pat
you domain yeah um and I will say this
my sense of safety is higher I'm not
sure if you can tell which most like you
can I'm [ __ ] America okay and uh and
uh overall I like it here and yo for
what foreigners they normally don't do
too much but right now they're actually
cracking down so but are you saying you
feel safer as a black man in China than
in the United States yes I do and I and
I I will actually tell I will actually
get some more my friends my colleagues
and people I share WeChat groups with to
call in to your show and they will share
a similar sentiment please all right I
look forward to hearing from them I will
correct your name and not cool Depp Oh -
we will update it to cool drop right -
from China I gotcha
okay thank you so much for the call
appreciated thanks for having take care
bye